so how does sort of crackling a web
series how does that differ from
crafting a feature film you know what
what are some of the things you can
point out to us you're the crafter I'm
the reader I think it's just I think at
least the way we're looking at the web
series um we were thinking of it with
with views in mind you know that the
Internet is a very crowded place and
well that you know a lot of us are
hopeful that more long-form can start to
be more mainstream on the internet right
now that's not the case so episodes have
to be a little shorter and you know you
need to keep the onions coming back for
more you have a very limited time spent
to to tell to introduce a character tell
a story and end it and then keep them
coming back for more grass when you have
a film you have that entire time you
know no one's going to hopefully walk
out of the theater you know the 45
minutes in um so I think with the the
web series it's important to remember
that even though you know you have a
whole whole season which essentially
comes out to the line typically of a TV
pilot every episode still has even if
it's only five minutes has to have a
beginning middle and um a beginning
middle end with that end having to you
know keep the audience clicking on that
next stop on that next video page and I
think um with the feature it's more I
guess at least for us which you
know maybe to our detriment in uh um
more mainstream distribution but it's
you know about like being able to like
really big into the story really you
know have fun with it over the course of
that 90 minutes rather than over the
course of like five minutes out five
minutes out of minute now I mean it's
just like you know it's it's one big arc
that you're following rather than like
our car car car car crescendo arc you
know where I mean that's the the web
format where you know everything like
you said you know house
beginning middle end beginning middle
end and you obviously don't have to but
that would be very strange film it's
room had that cycle throughout yeah like
I said there's obviously you know the
structure to a to a feature format on to
but it gives you you just you have more
time to get across what you want to to
get across um so long as you're you're
still making good use of that time
because it's you can easily fall into
the trap of and went through through a
feature as well um you have no if none
of that time in a web series that at
least right now I mean indie I'd be cool
to see one that did that would be pretty
awesome book or web series yeah and you
said the process of doing this going
from web series the feature and has been
very freeing and we can talk a little
bit more specifically on maybe how it
opened up and maybe how you're seeing
this story a new light higher see a
zombie these characters and the new life
yeah I think um well i think it's it's
just a mentality and you know maybe it's
because i'm more comfortable in you know
a feature versus a web series and and um
it's probably it's definitely more me
than the format but um just it became it
became very focused on where the where
the plot was at and it's very easy to
lose the characters with that it's a
harder juggling act um for me at least
in that time frame um what's the web
series some with arson what's your hand
resource it is that very well go ahead
no she's gonna say mean and mean it it's
honestly hard to remember sometimes then
what the original script was the web
series version cuz i now read this one
so many times but many think some of the
things were like changing in character
is like there was you know the Vikram's
character for example where there were
certain things that he was having him do
as part of the original script but this
character was was doing and i think it
was it because with the web series you
you are kind of balance
all the characters to you know you can't
have two episodes where all the
characters aren't there or you know you
you're missing somebody for a long time
so you kind of have to keep them in mind
as well but now you know what the
feature you kind of do have that luxury
of moving things around and shifting
them and I think Vikram was one of those
characters where I hey I don't think
I'll remember what you did cuz I way
know what the result is now but it I
think you like switched around who did
what or or that he came back or he
didn't come back or something along
those lines but I don't think I mean he
couldn't have done that with the
webseries Foreman so I think that's what
it was frame words I cool it doesn't
have to pick he doesn't have to be in
this part he doesn't have to be a part
of this part of the story and I think it
goes back to audience to because um
there's you know a certain type of web
series audience so there's the challenge
of you know have an indie sci-fi lofa
sci-fi drama which is going to be hard
enough to find its audience but to you
in try to introduce introduce people to
web series because that's still a new
girl in format um with that it's just
it's a it's a double challenge um does
it work
you